let's talk about DeSantis you know you
you have come out in favor of DeSantis
you had a uh a video op-ed or you know
on your YouTube channel it said
something like you know three reasons
I'm in favor of Ron DeSantis things like
that what is the case you know
succinctly because we're going to talk
about this for an hour uh but let's lay
out the thesis statement Ron DeSantis
for Libertarians like why should
Libertarians who are going to have some
you know kind of reservations about some
of the stuff he does uh you know and not
simply eating pudding with his fingers
um what's the case for Rhonda Santos two
Libertarians well first off I mean the
guy was part of the freedom caucus when
he was in congress with a bunch of other
guys that Libertarians seemed to like uh
he is the most I would say limited
government but uses government when it
should be used uh politician that we
have probably in America certainly now
at a national level uh you know Florida
I mean we can do a couple like just
basic libertarian things here Florida is
a no-income tax state that is great for
Libertarians uh Florida we have we have
the rule of law now I think we probably
have some little disagreements maybe on
levels of policing or that sort of thing
but Libertarians want to protect life
and want to protect property that's
being done incredibly well uh here in
Florida actually Zach you you mentioned
right before we started you live in one
of the few places that's Democrat run
now in Florida Florida which is almost
all red now don't forget DeSantis won
his first election in 2018 by 30 000
votes to a guy who turned out to be a
meth addict he won his re-elect by 1.6
million votes it's basically the biggest
landslide in Florida history he turned
what was at one time a blue State then a
purple State into basically the most red
state in the country and from what I've
seen he's really only using government
when it's effective and uh because I
know Libertarians don't like red tape
and don't like regulation we had that
unbelievably horrific it's less than a
year ago basically Category 5 hurricane
Ian hit Southwest Florida the rebuild
there has been so unbelievably fast
because he went in cut all the red tape
and they have rebuilt I mean I've been
there it's on the other coast I'm here
in Miami but that Sanibel Bridge it's a
three mile bridge it would have taken
any other state two years to rebuild
that thing they've had it functional in
about three weeks that's just one little
example of the type of things that he's
done he doesn't believe in government
and then we could do all the covid stuff
I mean he opened up the state he made
sure the kids were going back to schools
he was fighting against masks he you
know he's also trying to get ESG out of
all of our government institutions I
mean we could we could go on and on the
uh don't say gay law or the parental
rights and you know I think it's this is
something that
um I think Libertarians need to uh kind
of grapple with more fully which is that
Ron DeSantis signed what is you know
either the leading or certainly one of
the best school choice bills uh in the
state in the country yeah uh but then he
does this and he did this with masks he
did this with other things where he's
saying in order to preclude certain
choices I'm going to say at the state
level local school districts local
businesses can't make certain types of
choices and for me that's worrying
because what I see as somebody as he
gains more power is going to start uh to
exert his personal choices or a
conservative ideological agenda on more
and more aspects of everyday life right
can you just give me an example of what
you're talking about because I don't
know yeah yeah
so what I'm saying is is that if you
want school choice and if you believe in
parental rights you should give money to
parents and they can send their school
to their kids to whatever whatever
schools they want public or private but
then if you start to say okay and also
by the way schools cannot teach this
schools cannot do this schools cannot
XYZ that's confusing to me um and it
strikes me as maybe that's the
difference between being conservative
and being a Libertarian but I find it
worrying well well first off as long as
the government has anything to do with
education then somebody has to they're
going to fund it no actually they don't
really but no no I get the libertarian
position on this I I could get there I'm
all for school choice and if you want to
do you know what's happening right now
and it's largely in part because of
Florida's blueprint but it's happening
in Iowa and Arkansas and uh Montana and
several other states is funding of
students as opposed to systems I think
we're probably in agreement that that's
the best way to do it if you think that
there's should be any funding tax
related whatsoever I I don't have a
problem yeah I don't have a problem I I
am a uh a squishy libertarian okay so so
in that regard so if we're roughly
agreed on that well then the question is
okay so if you're saying you're going to
have some level of public education
somebody has to decide what's in that
curriculum now the fact is and I would
think that Local Schools would do that
local school districts Local Schools
sure parents and I mean why why is the
state getting involved in saying you
can't have this kind of curriculum you
can't have that kind of curriculum well
first off that's not that's actually not
what's happening I mean when people talk
about these book Bannings all they've
done is kicked it back to the districts
to say are you okay with certain books
in your school I think if you actually
give parents the right uh and the
ability to choose their schools you know
this stuff takes care of itself but then
to say okay any uh any discussion of
sexual orientation uh or of gender
identity in grades K through 12 or K-8
or at higher ed to try and squeeze out
whatever it passes for critical race
Theory these are troubling to me that's
and I'm saying this from a Libertarian
perspective I don't expect conservatives
to agree and I don't necessarily expect
uh liberals or progressives to agree but
this is what is I think this is the nut
that if DeSantis wants the libertarian
vote this is what he has to figure out
yeah and it's also just to return to the
Disney example for a second because you
know what what happened there is that
Disney had there's a basically
privatized version of government running
this area around Disney and then Disney
came the Disney CEO came out against
this education law you can agree or
disagree but that's his rights as a
private citizen and then they decided to
take a special look at this and I
interviewed the lawmaker behind this and
he told me that you know there's all
this pressure uh for companies to go
woke so they're going to learn that in
Florida there's consequences for that so
they're out there making statements like
this DeSantis every day has been making
statements that Disney is just jotting
down for their court case to show that
it's retribution like anyone who's
looking at the situation can see its
retribution and it's not just for Disney
there's other companies there's uh
Airbnb he went after them because he
didn't like that they pulled out of
operation their operations out of the
West Bank uh in Israel uh there's uh the
stop woke act where they
um prescribed they said that companies
could not engage in certain types of
diversity trainings and you know we can
have that debate about the public sphere
and what's appropriate in public schools
but my problem is that DeSantis often
just erases that or just glosses over
that public private distinction and I
find it disturbing for somebody who's
been considered uh to move up to the
presidential level yeah I I truly mean
this respectfully guys I hope it will
come across that way but this is why
Libertarians don't make inroads
politically because I'm not saying that
you're completely wrong on at the idea
level philosophically what you're saying
DeSantis fighting against diversity in
our schools you know diversity equity
and inclusion it's the most
anti-American actually
anti-constitutional idea that you would
be hiring certainly that the government
would be doing it hiring based on
sexuality and skin color and everything
else so if the it because then otherwise
it sends it seems to me that maybe and
maybe this is true Zach perhaps you're
more of an anarchist that they're real
that the government should sort of never
do anything you know because because
otherwise if the government never does
anything look again I said this earlier
but look again what book has
accomplished just in the last five years
it has demolished basically everything
we have the Democrat Party is basically
run by racists at this point and people
who want reparations and all of this
craziness finally someone has come in
and said I'm going to do my best to
clean this stuff up hey thanks for
watching an excerpt from our
conversation with Dave Rubin you can
watch another excerpt from that
conversation right here or the full
conversation over here and tune in every
Thursday at 1pm for more conversations
like this